top three atlanta rappers top three
that's easy
i'll do five whatever you want i will be
doing all the time or like my personal
favorite you have to do all the time if
i forget some people they're gonna be
mad at me okay this year all time five
no okay favoritism is definitely in this
by the way outcast jeezy i'm gonna go
future i'm gonna go young thug and for
the fifth one i know i'm forgetting
somebody i don't know about the fifth
one i can't remember well i'm gonna say
number one you had to say outcast you
passed that test i do have just like an
overall music question so i'm dirty i
listen to maybe just like a little
different music than some of the younger
guys everyone did this favorite rapper's
thing with nba and people were saying
like and be a young boy and like i'm
like i do not know when i'm being on my
song i don't think yeah like maybe i do
but i just don't know what it is you
don't heard one before who are the kids
listening to that i need to listen to
ghana is definitely one of them i listen
to god okay you talking about people you
don't know about do you listen to
babyface ray okay that's another one
i've like seen him i have no idea i only
see him because he kind of has like some
viral videos and stuff right yeah he's
somebody i've started listening to
recently that i really like any twitter
questions not twitter questions
questions
oh my bad i didn't want to forget
somebody in my past and then my dad be
like how are you forgetting
yeah but little baby definitely would be
in my topic so